you can imagine the
impact if i showed you pictures of the
room i was staying in
you would see for yourself that there
was no way i would that would have come
out of this alive
if you kill or you injure seriously
injure a police officer or any blue
light worker
there should be a minimum term it's not
enough
just having sort of black people on your
instagram feed or in a magazine we've
you know we've accomplished that
but now you know behind the scenes
that's where change really happens
these are species that can help us face
some of the most severe environmental
crises that we face
this was the moment an explosion ripped
through the city's port
and devastated neighborhoods for miles
around
the shock wave was felt all over the
city a place so scarred from decades of
conflict
had never seen anything quite like this
before
linda tamman is a journalist and radio
presenter in
beirut tell us what happened to you when
when this explosion occurred
i was exiting work the radio station
yesterday and just the minute i got into
my uber
the bomb went off so had i still been in
the office in the studio all the
the glass would have just poured in on
top of my head so you can imagine the
impasse
if i showed you pictures of the room i
was staying in you
see for yourself that there was no way i
would i would have come out of this
alive
and then my first reaction was what do
we do we had
hundreds of wounded people coming
towards us and trying to get into the
car
and begging every single car passing by
to take them to drive them to hospitals
so eventually i i you know i gave my my
cab to people in need and i ended up
walking and
and i've been on air ever since you know
i tell you it's been it's been a
whirlwind
uh for me this was really the last thing
not just the hospital needed but also
the the state itself you know we we were
suffering of
covet 19 just like the rest of the world
on top of that we had
a complete economic collapse and this
was really the last thing that lebanon
needed and just when we thought we had
hit rock bottom
this happened the worst part is that you
have people
you know missing their loved ones they
don't even know where they are some of
them are buried under the rubble
so we have at least 100 people missing
so far but on top of that we have people
who are wounded and injured and
they've been taken to hospitals and
their families don't even know where
they are and or how to locate them so
it's just a
plain catastrophe to say the least
people there must be shocked yes but
but furious too oh absolutely
absolutely some people uh you know
started taking to the streets
i mean this was just like i said the
cherry on top of the cake
we've already had so many
disappointments coming from our
government
not just disappointments but we were
literally let down as a people
and i think uh it's we've reached an
unprecedented
level of anger against our government
and it's it's a shame really i mean i
i just can't even i don't have the words
to tell you how angry we all are
and and and is it along with the anger a
sense of hopelessness too
for all the reasons that you that you've
just uh
outlined absolutely the problem is and
i've been saying this for a while and
i'm usually a very optimistic person
for the first time i just don't see the
light at the end of the tunnels i just
don't see it
and um i hate sounding so pessimistic
i just i don't know what the solution is
and the worst is every time i feel
that's it okay we can only go up from
here we've reached
rock bottom already it can only improve
something else comes up
so i pray to god that you know
eventually the wheel turns and
lebanon you know experiences a better
fit
[Music]
the mother of pc andrew harper who died
after being dragged along the road by a
getaway car
is calling for a new law which would see
anyone convicted of killing a serving
police officer
sent to jail for a minimum of 20 years
she's been talking to lisa dowd
i really believe that
we need a clear-cut system for how
things are going to be in the future
if you kill or you injure seriously
injure a police officer
or any blue light worker there should be
a minimum
term um we
didn't get what we thought was was right
for andrew but we've had to go through
this trial thinking we'd be
um in a different position now we've
um called this campaign andrew's law
we want to give a legacy to his name
um you know his his legacy isn't the
sentence that was received
i miss his comical
presence really um
just knowing that he's there and you're
you're not going to see him it's just so
difficult to pin down to one thing
it's he just lit up the room he was just
always funny and caring
i mean to anyone looking at they might
think oh you're dealing with it
remarkably well but what's the real
picture
for you the real picture is
you wake up in the morning people assume
that you've got
um you know you wake up and suddenly it
hits you
like a brick it's not like that it's
24 7 in my mind
it's it's a big it's a percentage of my
brain
24 7. so i don't sleep and forget and
have that feeling i wake up knowing
exactly
that he's he's not here debbie could you
um take me back to the moment that you
were told about what had happened to
andrew
waking up to a knock on the door
at 4 45 in the morning um
and two officers were stood at the door
and they kind of
said we come in and they were already in
really
and they just told me straight out they
didn't
um soft coat it which
is the right way to do it i think i just
just kept telling them to not tell me
um don't tell me that because it's
it's you just don't want to hear it and
you you try your hardest not to take it
in and not to believe it and then
they're standing there then you can't
close your eyes and open them and
they're gone they're still there
can you tell me why you've chosen the
blue lined
feather and the particular number to be
the kind of emblems for your campaign
yeah the
the number um was his shoulder number
and initially we were going to use a
blue line which has been used many times
before but
i went out to give some bird food out to
the robins the other day and then i
found this amazing
feather which was just sat there waiting
for me
and it's got a big it's a big black
feather with a big
bright blue stripe going down the side
and it just felt like a gift
this is the best way to honor him at the
moment
and make that his legacy something
positive that
reflects the injustice of what he's
sadly been put through
[Music]
back in april the former british tennis
player dan long was hospitalized
for six days with covid19 he's since
donated his plasma to the nhs
which is trying to establish if it can
treat patients struggling to develop an
immune response
just just tell us a little bit more
about your time in hospital
six days of it in fact
yeah that that as it turns out is a
relatively short
um time in hospital i i probably should
have
been more agreeable to being admitted
earlier
um but once i got in there i was
immediately put on
oxygen and thankfully i didn't
deteriorate any further
um one of my my biggest concerns
when i was admitted to hospital was um
was whether i would i would need
treatment in an icu bed but
um but i i got better and um the
consultants were happy to discharge me
after just
uh six days when my uh oxygen levels
returned to something like normal
how concerned were you when you went
into hospital it's never
never nice when one is forced into those
environments in the first place but
there must have been a degree of concern
yeah there was i
mean my body was was pretty much
shutting down and
and i think you naturally go into a
survival mode and
you have to admit there weren't actually
that that many lucid moments where
i i had time to think about the position
that i
i was in but i've been following the
news um i knew about the the statistics
around
um being admitted um to to icu and uh
yeah essentially i figured maybe it
would be a 50 50 chance if uh if
i find myself in that in that situation
so yes it was pretty
pretty scary um but what became
apparent to me neil is just how little
those caring for me had to turn to
um in in ways to to treat me and others
suffering from from covert 19. and they
do an incredible job
in the most difficult circumstances
but the reason why i am so
keen to get the message out there about
convalescent plasma
is because it could become the first
treatment that directly
attacks the virus itself because and i
don't know if people know this
widely enough that when you're in
hospital
all the doctors and nurses can do is
manage your symptoms
and convalescent plasma if you know the
trials
become successful could become a
treatment that directly
fights the virus and that's why this is
so important so what should people do if
they
if they want to follow suit if they want
to heed your advice and help out
it's donates you know it's a very simple
message here plasma
especially from people who have
recovered from covid19
may help save someone's life and
this is about mobilizing an army there
i've been i think to date over 130 000
hospital admissions and those that have
survived i see as
an army and the only way we can mobilize
that army and give the nhs
a viable weapon to fight this disease is
by donating
our plasma
edward eninful says he won't shy away
from controversy
and will use his platform to address
injustices
after three years at the helm the
biggest challenge facing the british
editor of vogue isn't who to put on the
front cover
but how to reflect a pandemic and a
global movement
tell us about the september issue the
the concept the idea behind it and
and what has materialized so the
september issue is a very special one
the cover was shot by a photographer
called nissan harriman
um he's a black photographer and it was
an all black team
we have marcus you know the footballer
from manchester
you know i mean he literally used his
platform to get
all the young kids fed that we have
adjusboa
um they're on the sort of the main cover
you know and address used
her platform to talk about mental health
we went from sort of women from you know
covey
to talking about environmental issues to
biggest moment in civil rights history i
mean
the whole world of the marches um
and i felt like these incredible
people who were sort of
given their time and their lives to make
sure
that there was social justice in the
world to make sure that there was
education
and community care these were the people
who were the new heroes you actually
went out on a march didn't you it was so
peaceful
people of all colors and all races were
there
and what really struck me about that day
about how
you know that george floyd's death
hasn't been in vain it brought
everyone together you've tweeted about
you know being at a fashion show and not
being sat
on the front row with your peers i mean
that was quite brave of you
when you walk into a show and all
fashion directors are in the front row
and you're in the second world straight
away that's you
you know profiling me um even
a few weeks ago the same thing sort of
happened the incident that you're
referring to
in the office when you're racially
profiled by a security guard in your
your own office
how did you feel when that happened it
wasn't an isolated incident of course
you know it takes you back to all those
moments in your life when that has
happened
and i think people people think that
when you're successful
that things like that don't happen for
me the beauty of that incident is it
just makes me aware
never to think i'm too successful are
you hopeful now that there
will be other edward eninfuls coming
behind you that people will feel that
the doors have been opened
i will make sure there is for me it's
been so important just
not being the only one but always
bringing people up with me and i think
it's so important you know the fashion
industry needs to you know employ more
people behind the scenes
recruitment i think it's not enough just
having
you know sort of black people on your
instagram feed or in a magazine we've
you know we've accomplished that
but now you know behind the scenes
that's where change really happens
[Music]
pablo escobar is the name of forgotten
how is it a name known to many
as the world's most notorious infamous
drug lord in a new book however his
firstborn son tells his own story
roberto sandoya escobar
was rescued as a baby following a
shootout in which
his mother died adopted by an mi6 agent
he never knew
his true identity until he was 24.
what we're actually talking about here
is a situation where
later on my adopted father the mi6 agent
has to tell me who i am and um that is
obviously a
a dreadful shock to me and um i asked
him what these vague
you know nightmare memories were that i
was experiencing as a baby and described
them to him and then
he obviously came clean with what had
happened to me
yeah i mean i guess in the in the mid
60s he he wasn't the sort of
colossus of the crime world that he
became i mean this was somebody who
yeah yeah so so effectively
um colombia was full of gangs uh you
know similar to gangs we have today in
inner cities really
uh and um a young pablo escobar was a
member of one of these gangs and
unfortunately
they decided to uh take it upon
themselves to
rob one of the armored cars of the uh de
la rue uh
operation in colombia which led to a
special forces raid on the
hideout of the gang where they got the
money back unfortunately there was a
young lady in the back room and she had
copped a bullet and
she was only 14 and there was a baby in
the cot
and this is all the stuff that dad told
me later and he was with her when she
died
and he's promised to look after her baby
boy and the boy was roberto cindy
escobar
the mi6 agent takes you under his wing
you go to an english
school for a while uh you know you get
set on this completely different
trajectory
pablo escobar tried to make contact with
you is that correct
contact was made by my adopted father
and all the complicated business
arrangements that are discussed in the
book
i remember it as clear as day you know
and i used to have to sit next to him
and
you know he would talk to me and stuff
like that i remember his smell of
cologne and hashish and
you know all that sort of stuff but um
yeah we did used to have to go and see
him
or have to i was told to go and see him
and i was flanked by my bodyguards i
felt okay but
i was confused and you know i didn't
know what was going on i was very young
child and and uh you know these were
just sort of things that i had to do
because the grown-ups told me to do it
and do you remember roberto when when
you heard that he'd been killed in this
shootout in what was in 1993
effectively um 93 was a terrible year
and at the end of the year i'm watching
the news in sunny wolf and on thames in
surrey and
and i see that you know the guy that my
dad had been telling me about has been
shot in the head and
and so yes very frightening and i
spiraled after that into a very bad
period of depression and
this is why i it took me you know over
20 years to write this
book i'll tell you what roberto uh
people write books
with about one percent of the interest
value of your life story that you tell
us or are going to be telling us in this
book
absolutely incredible and just one final
thought i know you you as an artist
you're known as
as philip whitcomb which name do you
prefer to go by one that tells the story
of your life although
yes i've got you know it's basically
i've got two nights two lives and two
names it's not
not a problem uh i've been called a lot
worse
[Music]
england's first wild beavers in 400
years have been given the permanent
right
to stay in their home in devon it means
the future is secure for the first ever
reintroduction
of an extinct native mammal to england
conservationists well they've been
welcoming the government's decision
they say there are many benefits to
having
beavers in rivers and what might those
benefits be
joining us from otterton is steve hussey
from the devon
wildlife trust tell us just a little bit
about the project how has it gone for
you guys
oh it's been an outstanding success i
mean devon wildlife trust and its
partners have worked hard over the last
five years to see
the first reintroduction of a british
mammal species
into an english landscape so that's
wonderful news
but it's good news i think there's wider
news that's better than that even that
and that is that these are species that
can help us
face some of the most severe
environmental crises that we face
in the 21st century so they can have an
impact a positive impact on things like
flooding and drought
and also on water quality so these
beavers come with as a package that
helps wildlife and helps people so what
is the next step are we are we going to
be seeing
beavers being reintroduced in in parts
of the country other than
devon now well the government has said
that it's now going to take some time
to consult wider the wider public on
what the future of beavers is elsewhere
what today's decision means is that the
beaver population which has been here
for the last five years
has a right to remain permanently and it
could spread to neighbouring rivers but
it's going to take a long time
before these beavers reach rivers on the
outskirts of london and elsewhere in
england so
it will need a reintroduction program a
wider one that's what we would hope that
the government decides to do in the
future but as i said they're going to
consult on that because beavers do come
with challenges they're not just a
species that simply
goes unnoticed they have an impact on
the landscapes which they populate
so does that mean that there has to be a
degree of management of any new beaver
population
that's been the key to the success of
this project we've worked with
landowners with farmers who have beavers
on their land
and beavers build dams that's what
they're known for and those dams can
create some local challenges they can
create localized flooding
but what those dams also do is hold the
water back in our landscapes
which means that communities downstream
which might be flood prone
see some relief from that threat and
also
beavers dams traps sediment the
pollution that runs off our
landscape off our fields and that helps
us in terms of water quality as well
but the people who pay for those
challenges the farmers who beavers
set up home on on their land they're the
ones that we have to support we have to
support them with
practical help and it may be that we
also pay them give them a subsidy
to have beavers on their land i i'm
really sorry steve i've got my director
giggling away in my ear as she looks at
pictures of what i have to admit are
incredibly cute
little animals but what happened to our
native beaver population in the first
place
well we don't know how the beavers got
here um they've probably been here for
more than
12 13 14 years but in 2013
we found out that they were breeding
here and then in 2014
the government announced they were going
to remove the beaver population that's
when we stepped in with local people
to set up a trial to see what impact
they would have
on the local landscape on local wildlife
and local people
and the culmination of that is today's
decision by defra that they can stay so
it's very positive news